my mom is one of the best cooks ever mom
gordon said z truck or a kiptech truck
just start selling cheese i mean my mom
is literally classic just i don't know
what you just said but i know you said
like the person are you asking your
mom's
like crack for middle class
i'm being real my mom is one of the best
cooks and i've eaten a lot of food from
a lot of different people my mom's going
to come visit she already made carrot
cake that one time that i almost got
arrested at the airport with the flowers
my mom put it remember that guys i can't
you want to laugh
with that
no no yeah flower hold on no no no no no
no no you want to show my mom i love i
think she's watching what's wrong my mom
makes a carrot cake and it's your
competition worthy care i'm not i know
people that's great patrick am i right
no jokes sick so i'm she's i'm coming
here i'm moving here we got the job with
pat and my mom makes this carrot cake
and
there's confection sugar that you're
supposed to put once you serve it she
puts it in the middle of the cake
without letting me know i show up to
[ __ ] lax my bag goes through and i'm
not joking you know the x-ray people you
can't really see them yeah it's a black
girl and she just sends up and she goes
oh hell no
i'm like what she's like is that you
cops everybody
i go what the hell is going on i'm i'm
not stupid i don't bring i don't have
drugs i'm not she goes what the hell she
pulls out this bag it's confession sugar
looks just like cocaine yeah and my mom
writes a no
this is sugar yeah don't
this is the first time we've gotten the
this isn't cocaine this is sugar trick
but like she my mom's cooking is amazing
we might have to open up a carrot cake
shop so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]